Hello World, Shawn Grooms here with Free Code
Camp.
And in this video I will be giving you three
tips on how to learn Discrete Mathematics.
The first tip is to stay calm.
People often hear the word Mathematics and
panic.
When you panic, you stop listening.
If you stop listening, you can't learn the
material.
If you simply stay calm, then you'll be able
to learn the material better.
You aren't being graded on the subject so
there's no need to panic.
The second is to rewind.
You can rewind the videos at any time.
When I learned Discrete Mathematics I didn't
have this opportunity.
In theory you should be able to learn the
material much faster than I was ever able
to.
I strongly encourage rewinding the video.
Finally, explain.
Once you think you understand the material
of the videos you can try to explain the material
out loud either to yourself or to a friend.
If no one is around, or you feel weird talking
to yourself then you can try and explain it
to a rubber ducky.
There's a concept in Programming called Rubber
Ducky debugging, which is where programmers
go through their code, line by line, trying
to identify bugs in their code by explaining
it to a rubber ducky.
So similarly, if you go through the material
of the videos, subject by subject, you will
soon be able to identify any gaps in your
understanding of the material.